now I'm more critical at this point and
where I'm at of the left because I'm
part of the left and I want the left to
be better I've long given up on trying
to fix the right right there that's that
you know I'm not gonna fix the track
already but I can at least I think try
to change for the better the part that
I'm with so that's why this is so
disappointing what do you make of this
idea that the that the far left is
attacking atheists of all groups of
people
it's astonishing I mean what what it I
guess one of the reasons why they
attacked the atheist is because they
might be some of the most vociferous a
group of of people that are critical of
religion in general but aslam in
particular and so to the extent that the
progressives don't like criticisms of
Islam and to the extent that many of the
most famous atheists are quite
vociferous in their criticism of Islam
and we have to go after them and I guess
this goes back to what you were saying
earlier but they don't seem to be able
to make the distinction when Bill Maher
relentlessly attacks Christianity nobody
calls him a Christian Arab right I mean
he made a documentary where he attacked
the big three religions relentlessly
nobody about selective processing of
information is a big cognitive bias
right so I will only pay attention to
information that supports my position
and that's exactly what the progressives
are doing they're ignoring the endless
times that Bill Maher attacks other
religions yeah but they only tune in
when he criticizes Islam I would bet and
someone can check this for us but I
would bet that Bill Maher has spent far
more time attacking Christianity because
he attacks things in this country far
more than then attacking Islam or
Judaism or whatever what do you make of
how much hatred there seems to be
towards atheists at the moment because I
see all these polls and on the show many
times we've done how atheists are the
most underrepresented group in
everything Barney Frank who was in
Congress for 30-something years was able
to come out as gay m80s but not as an
atheist until he retired from Congress
right what do you make of this cuz if
you just hold no power have-nots are
atheist killing people that I don't know
about right my feeling is that there is
a coupling of atheism and immorality in
the minds of most people so most people
believe that it doesn't matter which
religion you follow as long as you are
religious then you somehow have a moral
compass by which you live your life by
however atheists go around behind
puppies and then raping them for in the
minds of those folks and so an atheist
is not to be trusted because how
elsewhere can he get his morality if
it's not from some Bronze Age book right
so I think what you just told me is that
it's complete nonsense it is complete
lies I mean it could it be anything
other than that right I mean because
atheists simply aren't doing any exact
things know that's complete lunacy